[Música]
o inédito e o inimaginável são um
desafio de qualquer indústria pessoas e
companhias estão sedentos pelo novo mas
ninguém na real sabe como fazer isso
acontecer
criar formatos e experiências fora dos
roteiros convencionais é mais difícil do
que parece porque o confiável e
conhecido são pequenas conquistas que a
gente já fez e o paradoxo é que se você
quer um novo
tem que ser dessa pegar dessas
conquistas
tem que abrir mão do que você gosta dos
seus processos ou seja tem que se
desapegar do que você ama e não todo
mundo está disposto a fazer isso a ordem
é bom compartilhar com vocês três
provocações sobre como sair dos roteiros
convencionais
se você quer um inédito tem que explorar
o inadequado
não tenho outra coisa mas inadequada que
o fracasso em 2015 eu criei a primeira
foto ap na ti do brasil a reunião com
cerveja e fracassos
era tudo pra dar errado mesmo nível
mesmo porque só chegarão 14 pessoas eram
seis pessoas no comércio
e aí o formato é muito simples eu
chegava no palco e compartilhava os meus
fracassos
aí já na segunda em bento gonçalves
a gente mudou um pouco o seu formato
porque eu vi que tinha um tema tinha uma
curiosidade e as pessoas também queriam
falar então não sou eu falava dos
fracassos se a turma começava
compartilhar ahmed o tímidos mas
compartilhavam a ciatech 11 temos um
formato um pouco mais profissional onde
as pessoas compartilhando jeito mais
profissional fracassos pessoais e
profissionais
tenho uma vezes coisas muito comuns
o que eu mais gosto de saber e
experimento é que saiu de controle
totalmente
por quê porque hoje só um organizadas
por diversos grupos são todas as cidades
por a próxima coisa na sua casa num
bairro estão feitas hoje dentro e fora
das organizações vira um movimento
ministrem sabem uma revolução todo mundo
tenha hoje que falar disso e como eu
teve o processo de conhecer muitas
fracassados e muitos fracassos
tenho algumas descobertas para vocês
a primeira é que o tema a diversidade do
tema em calculável se vocês pensam os
caminhos do sucesso são previsíveis e
por isso portanto menos diversos
já os caminhos do fracasso são super
subjetivos e como fracassa um fracasso
de um pode não ser o fracasso do outro
então começa uma complexidade muito rica
sábio e aí nessa complexidade temos
outro achado muito lindo
é por isso que qualquer em qualquer
companhia de qualquer tamanho
infelizmente tenta silenciar o erro a
falha o fracasso os problemas e não
vemos benefícios que traz em que traz
precisamente face à consciência dos
problemas organizacionais
o maior benefício que eu já vi é
precisamente aqui e acompanhe a
amadurecer do jeito contrário se você
faz as tensões conscientes e fala o que
machuca está doendo você não repete as
mesmas coisas e transcendem a companhia
uma tática para a assembléia que sempre
que eu escutava todos os fracassos
contava uma história e o final sempre
foi a e achamos culpável achamos a culpa
à causa e tudo bem só que esse não é o
final essa deve ser o início
primeiro temos que entender que temos
que entender como fracassamos
daí botar alarmes aí fazer de criar
ferramentas para fracassar melhor e mais
rápido e ter um pensamento mais de
melhoria contínua
esse é o começo e não um processo linear
criança que assim sabe fica ou não fica
mais cíclico mais dinâmico e o que estou
falando aqui não é terapia não é
autoajuda também não é uma metodologia
sobre coisas aproveitar e usar o
combustível das pessoas que fracassaram
porque quem fez isso
quem foi a pessoa já fez esse
combustível todo mundo tem que usar de
um fato ea última coisa que eu quero
falar do fracasso é que sempre pensamos
l como se fosse do passado e não olha
vamos fracassar
amanhã também nós somos porque nós para
que possamos o mais lindo disso é que ao
mesmo tempo que você fica tão poderoso
fica tão vulnerável e aí acontece alguma
magia que tudo não tem que aprender a
segunda provocação é que se vocês querem
o inesperado
tem que aprender das catástrofes em 2016
tínhamos a missão de chacoalhar a os
pensamentos humanos da liderança de uma
empresa em porto alegre
e vocês sabem é como inserir pensamentos
divergentes como pensar diferente como
criar basicamente uma auditoria de
inovação
você pode escolher a clássica acabamos
todo mundo pensar como a gente faz um
projeto inovador 10 disseram e isso é
muito difícil para qualquer indústria em
geral
então o que a gente fez foi uma
provocação maior e o que fizemos foi
estudar tudo que tem a ver com a
catástrofe fez antes durante e depois
e criamos dinâmicas para esses
lideranças criar seus sonhos a partir se
isso acontecesse nos mercados onde eles
a tim tim duncan e do nada sério nada
começaram sair idéias muito inovadoras
muito criativas mesmo
e quando falo de idéias criativas é que
as idéias estão resgatando pessoas
termos como marketing e vendas estavam
do lado de resgatar vidas índice de
mortalidade
algumas coisas bem interessantes o que
mais gosto desse experimento é que
conseguimos aterrar numa linha super
assertiva e simples diz sabonete com
repelente uma coisa talvez que vai
salvar alguém além de limpar o que os
achava que as descobertas disso são
muito simples o foco o tempo
temos que criar temos que focar nesse
tempo no nosso processo de invenção e
não no resultado final
nós criamos um processo sabe a
imaginação gosta de ser seduzida não
gosta de ser direta mostra se abusiva
para os cantos
a segunda coisa que sabemos hoje mesmo é
que temos uma clareza na cascata de
inspiração a catástrofe foi uma
inspiração brutal uma fonte
depois alguém vai criar inventar algum
evento precisamente para alguma
tendência algum nicho e essa cascata
pode cair até um produto massivo no
serviço mestre mesmo e aí abre o leque
então o meu convite para vocês aqui na
próxima reunião seja lindo só que seja
levem por favor o terremoto do méxico
para criar um inesperado levem lá mas
mariana para ver como vocês conseguem
atingir isso leve a escassez da água do
seu bairro para ver como vocês
conseguiram agir
então temos que aterrar dessa triunfante
das catástrofes ação ea última é muito
mais simples porque essa é uma coisa que
pode nem aplicar agora saindo aqui se
vocês querem a sua presença ea
sincronicidade parem de perguntar e
responder o que você faz
sério devemos ser muito mais criativo
dos nossos encontros novos
estamos buscando sempre as pessoas novas
sabe com os mesmos roteiros e hoje eu
sei é que as descobertas nós devemos ser
muito mais agressivos para hábitos que
temos automáticos
essa pergunta tem todos os anos o cara
do velho faz o timbu faz o whatsapp faz
todo mundo
e devemos ser um pouco mais agressivos
para dizer isso não faço há dois anos
que eu não respondo nem pergunto isso e
uma das coisas bem interessantes e que
nós pensamos que abrem a surpresa sabem
mas não abre a conversa mas não fecha
surpresa eu sei isso agora fechar a
surpresa porque para mim é como se a
gente caminhar sem saber a surpresa tem
que chegar numa atitude muito passiva
nós temos que ser mais provocadores de
uma surpresa ativa para conhecer pessoas
novas
os meus encontros têm sido um pouco mais
curioso se um pouco mais os anos
um exemplo concreto é que conheciam caçá
11 de média idade ele agora faz dois
meses no méxico e meu convite para eles
foi bem de tênis e se preparem para
gritar
eles apareceram e aí quando apareceram
elles basicamente pensava realmente que
nós iríamos mostrar a elas mas quando
chegamos nas lutas livres do méxico
cara a euforia chegou como convidada é
um casal mexicano de mais de idade que
nunca tinha ido para as lutas livres tão
cara desconhecido levou eles saberão uma
coisa se começaram a gritar e isso a
eletricidade durou a noite toda
foi muito emocionante mesmo mas foi um
experimento que estou repetindo cada vez
mais outra outra
outro experimento muito bom que funciona
mesmo foi que eu não sabia também como
nessa pegada da rotina de perguntar o
que você faz
então lançou o seguinte convite
falei jantar na quinta
a única regra sem falar vamos aí também
não sabia o que fazer né mas aí
eu achei basicamente com essa embate com
esse convite a mulher das minhas vidas
então funciona entendeu mais ou menos
esse experimento duram as três horas até
que você ia falar nossa não sei acho que
acabou mas vocês vão entrar na algum
momento uma comunicação única fica uma
eletricidade depois de ser desse
instante muito forte e essa mas essa é a
felicidade aqui a gente tem que provocar
e nunca vou esquecer com certeza desse
encontro último encontro também que eu
nunca vou esquecer esse aqui é um
encontro e um de tim com 4 milhões de
morcegos e eu nunca pensei na minha vida
que é só existisse
quando chegarmos aí e vemos esse furacão
de morcegos
aí foi que o só vi que o impensável
hipnotiza
e esse é meu convite para vocês só vêm a
já no fracasso na catástrofe no avesso
forças únicas para hipnotizar e série de
notícias porque no final o que é a vida
uma coisa que você já leu ou eventos
inimagináveis que estão por acontecer
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]